et puis troisième sujet ça je pense que
c'est un point c'est un point très
important il faut bien comprendre
pourquoi on fait ce genre de réforme moi
il m'est arrivé de constater depuis deux
ans et demi maintenant que je suis mise
à l'intérieur que il y a des affaires
qu'on fait pas ou qu'on fait mal ou
qu'on fait trop tard ou qu'on fait bien
après parce qu'on n'a pas assez
d'effectif de police pour faire les
perquisitions vous savez qu'on fait des
grandes affaires de drogues ou des
grandes affaires
judiciaires vous avez besoin quand vous
faites 10 perquisitions en même temps
dans 10 endroits différents de beaucoup
de policiers de beaucoup de policiers
vous avez besoin d'enquêteurs vous avez
besoin de policiers suzure de voie
publique pour barrer les rues pour
regarder les sorties et donc il y a des
commissariats il y a des antennes de
police comme il y a pas assez de
policiers de police judiciaire on fait
un calendrier si j'ose dire de dire
quand le magistram nous donne le coup
parce que magistrat donne le logo
parfois la veille pour le lendemain
c'est pas si évident que ça ou quand on
va inter on va prendre un go fast ou et
on doit mobiliser 15 20 30 40 50 60
parfois 100 agents de police nationale
et on les a pas sur la préjudiciaire
donc du du coup en retard alors que là
l'idée c'est de dire que le directeur
sera au courant de ça il dira on arrête
tout demain matin on fait pas
l'opération de sécurisation du métro de
Tourcoing qu'on avait prévu vous voyez
on a un truc beaucoup plus important et
on contribue au 15 interpellations même
temps pour avoir l'épreuve et au 15
perquisitions en même temps on retarde
pas l'affaire en attendant que tous les
policiers de la pjdille évidemment je
caricature des propos c'est que vous
compreniez voilà et donc on sera aussi
plus efficace parce que
si je veux dire c'est la sécurité
publique qui devrait avoir un petit peu
peur de cette réforme parce que c'est
pas contrairement à ce que pense la PJ
la PJ qui sera omnie au service de
sécurité publique mais l'inverse c'est
les agents de sécurité publique qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux qui seront plus
utilisés par la PJ pour faire des
interpellations et ça laisse au policier
du spectre les grandes affaires mais ils
utilisent les policiers qui ne sont pas
des policiers de spécialisés de
préjudiciaire concourir à l'affaire
parce que pour faire des perquises vous
avez pas besoin d'avoir toujours des
policiers du du spectre je t'emmènerai
par dire et ça c'est un point très
important qu'aujourd'hui les sûretés
départementales et les commissariats
font des affaires qui étaient ceux de la
préjudiciaire d'il y a 15-20 ans moi il
m'arrive de lire des fiches où la police
la police nationale telle commissariat
fait 30 40 50 200 300 kg de drogue
ça arrive et c'est une sorte
départementale qui le fait ou qui
interpelle un type qui a fait trois
meurtre il y a 20 ans c'était pas comme
ça c'était très rare que quelqu'un fasse
plusieurs dizaines de kilos de cannabis
dans une cité maintenant j'ai pas que
c'est quotidien mais quasiment et c'est
la vie de l'EPJ du commissariat et je
pense que la préjudiciaire doit aussi
comprendre ça qui a eu une sorte de
montée en gamme très importante des EPG
de commissariat du fait notamment la
circulation de la drogue et à
délinquance qu'il est qu'il épouse
aujourd'hui à faire des affaires très
importantes et parfois ça va faire très
importante mais il y a pas de grosse
condamnation pénale parce que le PJ bah
il est peut-être devant une affaire un
peu trop grosse peut-être pas assez
formé peut-être pas assez spécialisé
puis on a chopé le gars on n'a pas chopé
le ramification parce que les gens se
parlent pas assez entre l'eau et le